In this course, you will learn
the basics of reinforcement
learning and how to implement it
using gymnasium. gymnasium is a
software library by open AI that
provides a collection of pre
built environments for
reinforcement learning agents.
In this course, Mustafa will
show you how to use gymnasium to
test and improve your
reinforcement learning
algorithms.
So what will be the objectives
of the course. So what we'll be
doing is, we'll be learning the
basics of reinforcement learning
and opening a gymnasium, you
will learn how to use the
gymnasium interface to interact
with different environments.
We'll explore various gymnastic
environments, so environments
could be like a taxi
environment, it could be like a
gadget environment, you can have
different Atari games as well.
And we'll also understand their
characteristics will build and
evaluate reinforcement learning
agents using given as
prerequisites knowledge of
Python programming language, so
you need to be familiar with
basic loops. What is a class
we'll have different methods. So
I'll explain it to you while as
we go along basic understanding
of reinforcement learning
concepts. So whatever the topics
are that are required, I'll be
explaining it to you. While we
are while we start the course.
Introduction to reinforcement
learning, what is reinforcement
learning, we will learn the RL
technologies. And also we will
understand the reinforcement
learning workflow. My next
section is introduction to
opening a gymnasium. So I'll
introduce you to open a
gymnasium and also we will set
up the gymnasium environment.
And I'll also I'll explain you
the basic concepts that are
required for using gymnasium. So
it could be the environment
agent observation, action and
the word. The next section is
gymnasium environments. So we'll
understand the types of
gymnasium environments. We will
understand the difference
between continuous and discrete
actions and observations
understanding the properties of
different gymnasium environments
and also the games classic
control Atari back to the
robotics we got different types
of the environments available
and there are many more
available so like Jack we have
taxi environment we have frozen
like environment. So now let the
next question is the gymnasium
interface will be interacting
with environments using the gym
interface will understand the
gymnasium API. And we'll create
some custom environments. Now
the next section is building
reinforcement learning agents.
So we'll be implementing RL
agents using gymnasium will
understand the algorithm Q
learning will be training and
evaluating RL agents using
gymnasium. And we'll be
improving RL agents with policy
search and other techniques.
Basically, we'll be solving
blackjack using Q learning this
will be the next section. So let
me just write it down
that will be the tutorial and
these are the advanced topics.
So after you get a basic
understanding of these of their
of reinforcement learning
gymnasium, and solve some server
problem, then it can go and
explore the other advanced
topics. So the these are the
using a porn AI baselines for
benchmarking RL algorithms,
creating and using rappers to
modify environment dynamics,
combining multiple environments
to create more complex
scenarios. So we can have two
taxes coming at each other. Or
you can have multiple players in
a poker environment. So
basically, you can simulate
those environments. Also, we'll
be integrating with other tools
such as TensorFlow and pytorch.
Okay, so basically, this is the
course. Now let's look at the
conclusion. So by the end of
this course, you will have a
very strong understanding of
reinforcement learning and open
air gymnasium, you will be able
to use the museum to build and
evaluate RL agents. And we'll
have a very good understanding
of the different gymnasium
environments available. This
code is an excellent starting
point for anyone interested in
developing or working with
reinforcement learning system.
Let's start with the basics of
reinforcement learning. It is a
type of machine learning in
which an agent learns to make
decisions by interacting within
the environment. So basically,
as you can see, I have an agent
and I have an environment. So
basically, let's take an example
of a robot to what will happen
is that the robot when it takes
an action Suppose it takes a
step forward. So, we will reward
either we will reward the robot
for that action or either we
will penalize it for the action.
So how will you decide that? So
what my basic policy would be
that suppose if the robot takes
a step and it banged into wall.
So, we will have to penalize it
and we will deduct some point
for that. Or if the robot takes
a step, and it doesn't bang into
anything, that will be a good
action, so we will have to give
it some points. This is
basically that's what will
happen. So, what is an agent? An
agent is an entity that
interacts with an environment in
order to learn how to make
decisions that will maximize a
specific goal or objectives. So,
basically, in our case, when we
have a robot need it to take
something from one place to
another place to the city, it
has to reach the particular
endpoint. So, we will have to
train the robot to reach that
goal. So, it will take the
decision autonomously as it
receives input from the
environment, perform the actions
and receive rewards or penalties
based on these actions. The
environment on the other hand is
the external system or context
in which the agent operates. So
basically, in our case,
everything that is nearby to the
robot is the environment. So
basically, it could be a
warehouse to the full warehouse
will be the environment and it
will be interacting with the
robot will be interacting with
the environment. So it can be a
simulation of physical system or
any other system that the agent
interacts with. The environment
provides feedback to the agent
in the form of rewards or
punishments. When the agent uses
to learn how to make better
decisions. The agent receives
feedback in the form of rewards
or penalties. So as we discussed
earlier in the robot kills, when
he takes a step forward, and it
doesn't matter to wall, we will
give it a reward. And our goal
is to maximize the total reward.
So if it takes a step forward,
and doesn't bind it to anything,
it will eventually reach the
goal. So it is a trial and error
process, observing the
consequences and adjusting its
behavior based on the rewards it
receives. Over time, the agent
learns to identify the actions
that lead to the highest rewards
and avoid those that lead to
penalties. So as we keep
training the robot, it will
eventually learn what decisions
to take autonomously. So it
adapts to new situations and
environments. And it will adjust
its behavior based on the
feedback it receives and improve
the performance. And it will
become efficient decision maker,
which leads to better
performance as well. So let's
also look at some real world use
cases of reinforcement learning.
So basically, the example that
we covered is robotics. We could
perform tasks such as grasping
objects navigating and
interacting with humans. For
example, RL has been used to
train robots to play tennis,
table tennis, where the robot
learns to adjust its movement
based on the position of the
ball. So let's look at another
example of which is the game
playing. So like the most famous
example is of Atari Games. So
like DeepMind launched Atari
game module. Reinforcement
Learning has been applied to
game learning, particularly in
the development of artificial
objects. Or we can also talk
about Blackjack, we can talk
about chess, so a lot of games,
Atari Games AlphaGo, a computer
program developed by Google
DeepMind, which is reinforcement
learning to learn to play the
game of go at a world class
level. Also, we can use
reinforcement learning for
autonomous driving.
Reinforcement learning can be
used to train autonomous
vehicles to make decisions in
complex and dynamic
environments. For example,
reinforcement learning can be
used to train a self driving car
to navigate to the traffic,
world obstacles and make safe
and efficient driving decisions.
Also, another very good example
is of personalized
recommendations, which is
basically Netflix or Google
recommendations. Reinforcement
learning can be used to provide
personalized recommendations to
user based on their preferences
and behavior. For example, we
can use RL to optimize the
recommendations of a video
streaming service, learning what
content to recommend to the
users and to maximize user
engagement and satisfaction. So
now we have learned about the
agent and the environment. So
now let's move on to gymnasium,
which is a toolkit that will
help us simulate these
environments for our agent. So
basically, it is a set of a
collection of environments, or
tasks that can be used to test
and develop reinforcement
learning algorithms. These
environments are typically game
like with well defined rules and
reward structure, making them
useful for evaluating and
comparing different
reinforcement learning
algorithms. So what I'll do is I
head over to the documentation
page and show you the different
types of environments that are
available. So this is the
introduction page. So basically,
it is just two lines of code to
set up an environment and you
can interact with the
environment as well. So I
encourage you all to go and
check out the documentation and
also explore the different types
of environments that are
available. So we have a Cardpool
environment we have a mountain
car. Also interesting
environments. We have a car
racing environment as well.
Basically, for gymnasium, there
is only one single agent. But if
you want multi agents, then we
have another library called
petting zoo. We have a bipedal
Walker here. And another
interesting environment is
obliging environment. So in this
tutorial, I'll be covering
blackjack environment. And
another environment is a taxi
environment. So basically, this
is like our cell running
example. Also, we have a frozen
lake environment, forking, these
are all the very interesting
environments. So it could range
from games like Pong, or record
to more complex simulations like
robotics or autonomous driving.
The NASM environments are
designed to be easy to use, and
come with a standard interface
for interacting with the
environment. Now, basically,
what all steps do, we need to
start interacting with
gymnasium. So let's check it
out. So we need to define the
environment that we want to work
in P to create an instance of
the environment. So that's what
we did here. So basically, we
use them that make and use the
environment that we want. We
will define the agents policy,
how it decides which action to
take, interact with the
environment, taking actions and
receiving rewards, update the
agents policy based on the
reward it receives. So just to
go back, we have an example of a
robot. When we take that example
and apply these rules, we'll be
able to interact very easily. So
let me just to show you how we
can do that to an environment
will be the warehouse
environment, an instance of the
environment we'll create first,
we'll define the policy. So in
our case, the policy was that
once the robot takes a step
forward, and if it doesn't crash
into a wall, or even cat class
into another word, that is a
successful step, and then we
reward it, otherwise, we'll have
to penalize it. So basically,
this is the fourth step, we have
to update the agents policy. So
what we have to do is we need to
update it that once you take a
successful tip, you need to keep
taking successful steps and you
will in the end, and we'll keep
repeating it until our
performance is satisfactory.
Some of the main concepts we
will need in open AI gymnasium.
So the first we have is
observation and action spaces.
And our observation space is the
set of possible states that an
agent can observe in the
environment. And Action space is
the set of possible actions that
an agent can take in an
environment. So let's take the
example of our robot. So what is
the thing is that I have my
robot right here. And the
possible actions that it can
take is either it can travel in
the front, or it can double to
the right
or to the left or take a step
back. So this is the possible
action space that can take also,
in this case, the observation
space will be an ideal place to
be 567 action space is different
than the observation space. This
is the full action space and
observation space will be
changed.
This is action space. This is
the observation space. Let's
look at episode. An episode is a
complete run through of an
environment starting from the
initial state and continuing
until a terminal state is
reached. So let's look at that
in our example as well. So I
have my robot right here. And I
wanted to reach here. So this
would be an episode and I can
train the robot to run multiple
episodes. So it will start at a
particular position and it will
reach this terminal position. So
that will be one episode it will
start there and could go here as
well. Basically, this could be a
terminal location or it could
this could be the start location
and this could be the terminal
location. These are all the
different episodes that we have.
Each episode is composed of
sequence of states action and
towards rapper rapper is a tool
in open engine that allows you
to modify and environments
behavior without changing its
code. So we'll look into that
later on. Wrappers can be used
to add features such as Time
Limits, reward shaping, and
action must be benchmark open
and Jim provides a set of
benchmark environments, which
are standardized tests that can
be used to evaluate and compare
reinforcement learning
algorithms. So if we have
multiple algorithms for a
particular environment or a
problem, we can use the
benchmark to compare them We are
done with the basics of
reinforcement learning. And also
we have learned the agent
environment and everything that
is needed to get started. So now
let's implement the game of
blackjack using gymnasium.
First, let's get introduced to
the game of blackjack. So what
are the basic rules, so the
basic rules is that I need I
will have two cars and the
dealer will have two cars. Now
in this scenario, both will be
AI players. So the thing is that
at each turn, I will have to
decide that I need a new car or
do I want to keep my current set
of cards, but the dealer has to
keep playing until he until the
E reaches over 70 The sum of the
card which is over 70 And if I
have to when I need to be a
bigger number, then my some of
the cards have to be greater
than the dealer's card. So let's
go over all the basic rules of
blackjack. This game is played
with one or more decks of
standard playing cards. Each
dealer is dealt two cards and
the dealer is also day two cards
with one card facedown. The
value of each card is determined
by its rank. Aces can be worth
one or 11. face cards kings,
queens and jacks are what 10 and
all other cards our their face
value. Players have the option
to hit and take additional cards
to improve their hand or stand
and keep the current trend, the
dealer must hit until their hand
has a value of 17 or more. If a
player's hand goes over 21 The
bust and lose the game. If the
dealer's hand goes over 21 the
player wins the game if neither
the player nor the dealer bust
the hand with the highest total
value that is less than or equal
to 21 wins to basically these
are the rules now let's head
over to the gymnasium
documentation and check out how
blackjack is implemented. So
here we are in the gymnasium
documentation now let's check
out the action space and
observation space here. So
basically we need to import
blackjack we want to create the
blackjack environment this is
the rules that we discussed no
action space the action space is
one comma in the range of zero
comma one indicating whether to
stick or hit. So it's a player's
decision with a dealer has to be
played the observation consists
of a three tuple containing the
Players Current sum the value of
the dealers one card one to 10
where one is is and whether the
player holds a usable is one or
zero. Basically this will be the
observation space our starting
space will be four between four
and 11 dealer car has to 11 and
other usable is if I ever usable
based on what will be the
rewards in this particular
reinforcement learning problem.
So we'll have win game as plus
one lose game as minus one draw
game is zero and win game with
natural blackjack plus 1.5 If
natural is true, and this one if
natural is false. So basically
this is another type of set that
is the natural environment. So
basically we can understand that
with natural is true whether to
give an additional reward for
starting with a natural backdrop
that is starting with an ace and
10. So we can specify that when
we set up the environment. Now
let's see how we can implement
it in Google collab. Now we've
covered the basics of blackjack.
Now let's understand how we can
solve this game of blackjack. So
let's first discuss a book that
is very popular regarding to
blank that it's called
reinforcement learning and
introduction by Richard Sutton
and Andrew Bartow. It covers the
basic applications of
reinforcement learning. And also
there is a chapter on Blackjack,
and it also covers other games.
And they have modelled it a
Markov decision process, and how
every action influences the
outcome of the game. Now also
they explain how reinforcement
learning algorithms can be used
to learn optimal policies for
playing blackjack based on
maximizing the expected return
over the long term. So now this
seems really complicated, but
this is the beginner course you
don't need to learn this. Once
this course is over and you
still have a curiosity you can
go check out this book. And
because why should you check out
this book because it presents
several approaches to solving
the blackjack problem including
Monte Carlo methods and
temporary difference learning.
It also covers value functions
and policy improvement, which
are a very advanced topics. So
maybe we can create a course on
that but as this is a beginner
course, you do not need to know
all these. So let's start with
the basic implementation. What I
will be doing is I will be
importing the libraries that
we'll be needing for us to
install I'll be copying this
multiple times
and I plot lib, then let's do
NumPy. See one. So basically
NumPy is used for data
manipulation. As we import I
just explained to you when we
bought what each library is used
for, take UDM we are in
synchronism.
0.2 7.0. So basically, this is
the LT S support Long Term
Support version. And let's do
matplotlib in line. So, as you
all know, when accurate lib is
used, it opens a new window. But
in collab, Google collab, there
is no window. So basically, the
plots should be in line. So
basically we'll do this
percentage matplotlib in line
30. So all the plots below the
cell. So yeah, it's done, let's
do pip install. So I already
have it installed, but in my
machine, it'll take some time to
install by till it get
installed. Let's also import all
the necessary materials that
we'll need. So from collections,
I will import defaults. So why I
am using a default is because it
allows us to access keys without
checking that if the value is
accessed, its value exists from
input map plot lib.pi plot as
PLT. So this is just also write
down why we'll be using
access to you find the keys keys
that do not exist. Check for us,
instead of us having to always
check if that keys exist, it
will just take it for us. We'll
be using this for going clots
from Mac lot plot lib dot
patches. So basically this is
for creating shapes or shapes.
Let's import NumPy. So NumPy is
very popular. Michigan NumPy is
for array manipulation and image
manipulation. Manipulation
there's two input C one C one is
a very popular data
visualization library as soon as
and from TQ DM so basically this
is for a loader. So whatever
training that happens, it will
show it as a loader. So to be
very easy to understand cleaning
covers. So I think we have
completed the installation of
the basic libraries. Now let's
so let's so what I'll be doing
is I'll be using the Jim that
make command to create a
environment so it will be env is
equal to Jim. So I've already
imported the gymnasium. Okay, I
forgot to input let me import it
as well. So from import
gymnasium. Now let's do gym dot
make. So our environment name is
Blackjack, we won. Check we
want. And what I'll be doing is
I'll be setting the SAP
parameter to true what is SAP
parameter it is the natural
environment, basically the
default state of certain and the
book that we discussed. So what
I'll be doing is and also I'll
be setting the render mode is
equal to RGB grid because I'll
be showing you the training
states so exactly what is the
position of the card at that
particular moment in training?
That will be interesting to
watch. That is why I will set
this render mode to RGB array.
Now let's go and see how we can
set up the environment. So I
will be observing the
environment what I'll be doing
is I'll be setting this as Let's
observe the environment
so we'll be using the NV dot
start method to observe an
episode so basically we
discussed what is an episode in
is basically all the steps that
it takes for me to reach from
the starting point to the
endpoint once. Basically, that
is an episode. And for sitting
in Episode, we do it as
observation, comma info is equal
to en v dot reset. So basically,
we use the reset method to reset
the full board, or you said the
particular environment. And
we'll be keeping done as far as
because we have just started the
training, let's do let's have
some comments. They said no
environment
first observation So, and what
will be the output of this, so,
observation is equal to it is a
tuple. And as we have discussed
before, it will be 16 Nine and
false. So what is this tuple. So
basically, this is my hand, what
I have been dealt, this is the
dealer's hand. And this is the
number of if, do I have an ace,
so, I don't have an ace at the
start, that is why I caught the
output as false. So, it is a
Boolean and it is like the this
value deposits that if I have a
as usable without busting So
yeah, that is the thing, if I
can have an ace, but I can also
bust as well. So, this is a an
ace which is usable, and without
busting. So let's write that
down as well. So, what this
output let's
consistently when is
the first value in the current
some, the second will be value
of dealers sub called the third
will be Boolean whether the
player holds, holds usable is
and what is a usable is where it
is usable.
Yes, it comes without busted.
Basically that is let's see how
we can execute that. So, for
executing an action, first we'll
receive our first Object
Observation should be basically
that will be the starting space,
we'll be going to then after
that we'll be using the end
third step. And we'll be giving
the action to interact with the
environment. So in whatever
example of the blackjack, it
will be that if I want to take a
new cart, or do I want to keep
my current set of cards that
will be passed in the action.
This function takes an action as
an input and execute it in the
environment. Because that action
changes the state of the
environment, it returns four
useful variables to us these are
next state. This is the
observation that the agent will
receive after taking the action.
It will also give us the reward
the Agent will receive after
taking the action. Either this
environment has terminated or it
will give us truncated that if
the episode ended early, or the
time limit is reached. This is a
dictionary that contains
additional information about the
environment. The next reward
terminated and truncated
variables are self explanatory,
but the info variable requires
some additional explanation.
This variable contains a
dictionary that might have some
extra information about the
environment. But in blackjack v
one environment you can ignore
it. For example, in atari
environments, the info
dictionary has a fairly short
lives key that tells us how many
lives the agent has left. If the
agent has utilized then the
episode is over. So basically,
these are the four values that
are important. After we take a
step two let's see how we can
take a step now. So let's take a
new cell and let's take the
action. So action equal to NV
dot action underscore space dot
sample
now what is this? This is a
sample action that will be
taking sample a random action
Basically, this is the training
loop. So that's why we are
taking a sample exam. All valid
actions. Now we have hash action
is equal to one. And what we'll
do is we'll execute, execute the
action, we see how we will be
executing it. So we'll be taking
observation. So we discussed all
the parameters here, right, so
we'll be taking all the four
parameters, we'll be having
reward, we'll be having
terminated, truncated, and so
forth. So we can ignore info but
I be taking input, just in case
an action so action is the
sample exit from here. Execute
the action.
So we'll be receiving input and
receive info after taking it but
taking the step. So what will be
the output if we run this so the
sample output will be the
division is equal to So
basically, we have learned what
this tuple means. This is a 24
is my current sum to basically
I've gone bust. Now, also,
first, I do not have any usable.
Basically, this is just a sample
start. So I have some values
here. So I'll explain to you all
these values. So and reward is
equal to minus 1.0. So
basically, I've lost, so
terminated will be true.
We have truncated
and hash info, we call to
length. So yeah, this, this is
how it's going to be for this
particular one simple step. So
once we get the word terminated
is equal to true, what do we do
then the current episode, we
have to reset. So if terminated,
I had to take a text.
needed is equal to true or we
should stop the current episodes
and begin a new one using en
with a reset. So basically, I've
talked about this method before
as well. And this is what is a
single action that we take in
this particular environment. Now
let's build our agent. So now we
have committed the basic setup
of the environment and our
agent. Now let's understand the
approach that we'll be using to
solve like that. So let's look
at the epsilon greedy strategy.
This is a very optimum strategy
to solve that. So let's
understand it. In this strategy,
the agent takes an action that
is either the best action based
on the current policy with a
probability of one minus epsilon
or a random action with a
probability of epsilon. This
approach balances the
exploitation of the current best
policy with exploration of new
policies, which can lead to
better rewards in the long term.
So basically, it is a very
strict policy. Either I take the
current best policy or current
best approach, or action, or
either take a random action. So
how you set the policy let's
let's look at that later. But
let's understand the epsilon
greedy strategy. In the context
of blackjack, the epsilon greedy
strategy can be applied to
determine whether the player
should hit or stand at each step
of the game, the agent, that is
the player can choose to take
the action that is either
recommended by the current
policy, or it is a random
action. The policy is learned
over time by updating the action
value estimates of each state
action pair based on the rewards
received during the game. As the
game is played repeatedly, the
agent learns the optimal policy
that maximizes the expected
rewards. Basically, we as we
keep on running the iterations
and the agent keeps learning, it
will understand the optimum
policy that will maximize our
expected reward. Initially, the
agent may explore by taking
random actions to discover new
strategies. However, as the game
progresses, the agent will start
to exploit the best known
policy, which should maximize
the expected reward over time.
So this is the approach that
we'll be using. Now, let's build
our agent using this approach.
The epsilon greedy strategy
Okay, so let's take a code cell
and create our class. So
basically, we'll create a
blackjack agent class. And let's
do def, we define the initial
constructor that is a default
constructor. And what all
parameters do we need for this,
so we'll take the self
betterment of the learning rate.
Basically, this will be passed
as epsilon, this will be a
float, stick initial epsilon be
a float as well. Let's take
epsilon decay is a way of float
as well. Let's take final
epsilon
should be a float as well. And
let's take the discount factor
and this will be 0.95 in this
case, so we have completed the
initial Garaventa. Let's move
ahead and create our initial
complete the initial
constructor. q underscore value
is equal to default IC so we'll
be using default because we do
not want to always check if that
key exists to be a lamda method,
lambda function and P dot zero
Yeah, so we can just initialize
it as
np dot zeros. Let's set it at E
and V dot action space
dot n. Now let's read some
comments as well just for
explanation. So what are we
going to do we are going to
initialize or also whenever I
say RL it is it is a
reinforcement learning agent
with empty dictionary
of state action values. This is
the key values learning rate and
epsilon. Arguments let's
understand all the arguments as
well. So we'll be calculating
the learning rate.
So, I think these are pretty
self explanatory, let me just
explain to you the discount
factor. So, the learning rate is
the learning rate itself, the
initial epsilon value, epsilon
decay, the decay for epsilon and
this will be the final epsilon
value and the discount factor is
something that needs to be
understood. Let's understand the
discount factor discount factor
for computing the Q value so
I'll explain to you what the Q
value is just first complete the
basic class of our agent.
This is the approach that we are
going to be using using Q
learning to solving blackjack
using Q learning. So, now let's
complete our consulter
basically, this is the learning
rate. discount factor is equal
to discount factor
epsilon be able to initial
better know also good epsilon is
equal to initial epsilon loop
self dot epsilon DK
single equals
final epsilon going to final
underscore epsilon cuts to the
training error says training
error is equal to blank correct.
Now let's create another method
that is the get action method
basically, I need to complete
the integration. Let's do that.
It may complete the end
condition yeah
I'm just looking at
this is a tuple that we
discussed observation tuple that
we'll be getting, which is
intelligible and the output will
be an integer. So this will be
the get action method where
we'll refine the policy. So if
np dot random dot random maybe
doing random is less than self
dot random dot epsilon
so I think I could do return in
v dot action underscore sample.
So we do taking the sample
action instead of taking the
correct action. Yeah, else if
the probability is, is good
enough. Let me take the return
of n p dot arg max dot q. So
basically, this is the key
values that we'll be using your
so I'll explain to you in just
some seconds. Me complete all
the methods. So let's let's give
it some parameters here.
Basically, this is this will
return
return the best action be at one
minus epsilon otherwise random
action with probability explore
for exploration. So yeah, this
is the basically the approach
that we understood before.
And short exploration. Let's
create another method first
printing of what are the Q value
is, so basically, let me just
write it down here. So the Q
value function
is used to estimate the optimal
action to take in each state,
the optimal action in a state is
the one it is the one
that maximizes expected long
term rewards. So basically,
we've understood the epsilon
approach to basically this is
how we'll be maximizing it. Now,
this is a bit complicated the
equation there is an arg max,
which will return the maximizing
value. So I encourage you guys
to go and just understand the
logic behind it. It's pretty
complicated, but it is this is
basically the optimal action
that we have to take in each
step. Basically, this will be
calculated for us in our in our
game, pls. Let's move on now we
need to complete the update
method for it's complete that
you have our def update and it
will have self observation. You
see this is the operation tuple.
So like you might be having some
errors. So when we compile it,
we'll get to know all the
actions that do reward the
workload to terminated boolean
and do next observation. Again,
and to kill it.
So we've understood what the cue
function is basically we'll be
updating the cue function
so let's understand it. Future.
value is equal to not terminated
into np dot max self dot Q
values of next observation, we
will be taking the Q value of
the next observation and
multiplying it with the
terminating method. So, if it is
terminated, then we have to
start again, if it is not, then
we know, we know what need to
calculate this equal to. So, he
has the reward. Basically, this
is the method that is a
function. So, explaining to you
how we calculate it discount
factor into future Q value minus
Admittedly, this is the literal
formula that we use to calculate
it will explain to you, but
let's go ahead and complete this
method. Observation of action.
Three, and this is done the
queue method, key values done.
Let's do the training. But now
we need to update the Q value.
Now, we have completed the
difference now let's do the self
dot q values of observations and
of the action 2d array is equal
to self dot values. So,
basically this is what we have
to do again, you score values
I'll be copying this plus self
dot x revisit the learning rate
into the temporal difference
and this will be self dot
training dot append temporal
difference now, let's compare
the last method that dT d k
epsilon.
Lot salon minus salon decay was
ugly we have completed our class
like the agent. So, now we've
completed the class of our agent
three and we've defined all the
actions that the agent can
perform. Now let's see the
training of the agent. So let's
start the training. We'll be
taking it one episode at a time.
So let's do the parameters for
servers we'll keep the learning
rate 0.01 Visit the learning
rate we have the episodes equal
to 100,000 we can change it like
just keep it 100,000 Because
that's will give us a very good
trained agent, but I'll just
reduce it for the tutorial. This
is the standard that you should
keep if you want to get a real
world agent to start
shorts by two so we reduce the
exploration what time we wanted
to take the appropriate path
without having to explore too
much to this will basically
reduce it. Then we have the
final epsilon which really this
is where we need to get by the
end of the training. Let's
create our agent this is this
these are all the parameters the
hyper parameters doors, we have
agent is equal to have a black
agent learning rate.
learning rate we have the
initial which means you can just
pop up on intubated is equal to
start. Start if you don't have
one, and basically we need to
get to 0.1 from one
and we have epsilon decay is
equal to epsilon decay. It's
past that. Now also let's do it
the final epsilon. So this is
the agent that we need Hello. So
now, let's turn the training
let's turn to training now. So
basically we have completed the
agent setup now. Now let's start
the training. So what I'll do is
I'll just set up the environment
in v is equal to gym dot
rappers, not record. So we will
be recording all the statistics
and I will just show you after
the training, how the agent
improves over time. So will you
plotting some charts as well. So
let me complete the training
part first. And then we'll talk
about what the training has, how
the training has improved over
time, and what kind of all the
statistics would mean. We'll be
putting charts and also I will
give you the statistics we have
episodes and episodes okay, it
will be recording the statistics
for episode now let's do that.
So we have under 1000 episodes,
let's make it 10 For this
tutorial, just to that it will
run pass. So I will also output
the environment at particular
point so I will so every time
that a card is dealt or anything
that is decision is made by the
agent will be plotting that
particular environment and see
the what is happening in real
time. So I'll be doing that as
well. So it's like watching live
play live poker in real time.
Live blackjack and play time. So
let's do that. Let's let's do
that. Now. We do end with a
reset. Now why do we do in
winter reset because as we
discussed, after every episode,
we need to reset the
environment. Because I have
traveled from one point to
another point I need to reset
the environment. Okay, so done
is equal to false because we
need to complete the challenge
need to get to the endpoint need
to clear up now I need to
import. So what I'll be doing is
for every episode, I will be
carrying the output because I'm
only interested in the current
episode and what is happening
right now in real time. So I'll
import it IPython display input
clear output. Basically, this is
what I need to import. So
basically for every episode,
this will clear the output. Now
let's complete third training
for one episode. result we play
one episode as do while not
done, so is also while we are
not done, let's run this loop.
Let's do action equal to agent
dot get action of observation.
Let's do next underscore OBS
comma toward comma terminated
whistle all the information that
we'll get after making a
particular step should be
truncated the info equal to E NV
dot step. Let's update now let's
do agent dot update. We'll be
passing all these parameters, we
have to pass observation action
reward terminated and the next
position. Next observation
frame. So basically I will be
rendering the frame so at
particular instance what is
happening we can just output
that as well. So I'll be doing
that we will able to end the
Render loop PLT dot I am show
frame from Python, I'll be
showing you the exact location
of the cards and exact position
of the gods exactly what is
happening in real time. Now,
what we have to do is we have to
check if that episode is
terminated. So how will we know
that we have a parameter called
terminated or we have truncated
so truncated is that we have a
bust or terminated is that the
time limit is oh observation is
equal to next observation. And
we have to do agent. So I am
excited to follow me to agent
dot d k, epsilon. So over time,
it will get smarter. So this is
it. So I'll be using the package
called annotations because I'll
be using subscripts in my
methods. So I got an error here.
Now let's run it and check
again. If you're also getting an
error, make sure to import the
package annotations. Now
everything's done fine. Let's do
it. Yeah, basically. Basically
this is like running an ad is
not defined. So it is not
defined. So I'd say okay, it
should be brutal basically these
things happen yeah this sounds
fine now that's tribes but
agreement equal to equal to
where is that here let's see
what I can do record episode so
it is en mi comma non thought
basically these things happen so
so there is nothing in the
gymnasium that happens so it is
rappers no rapper also has no
attribute record episode
statistics so it is Np p Saudia
obviously, this is episode
statistics
now in Opie is not defined for
is not OB, this is our OBS, this
is observation space. Now, we're
gonna continue to add episode
when they already exist. To see
why that happens. Everything is
done, let's run everything
through run all. Now if you get
some errors, just make sure to
check out the integrations or I
just link my Google colab
notebook in the description, you
guys can go and check it out.
Because there were a lot of
integration issues before
running it. Now that's it. So as
you can see, for every episode,
we are able to visualize it. So
divisibility when you 121, then
it's a drop in both are 21.
Let's see it is 12 It's pretty
fun to watch. So now currently,
I've said the episodes over
100,000, I can change it and
keep it as 10. But I'm just
gonna let it train. So once that
is done, I just come back and
let's just visualize the
training part of them. Because
we need to understand the error
losses and we need to understand
the policy that we have used.
This is running, let's just
complete the visualization code.
So what I'll be doing is rolling
land. So we will be
understanding all the parameters
and all the data relating to our
policy and understand what is
the appropriate amount of
episodes that we couldn't use,
and also the loss function.
We'll plot it and we'll
understand it that way as well.
So let's do that. So what I've
done is I've set the rolling
length is 500 and I've done the
finger sizer so I let me just
complete the code and I'll
explain to you everything what
we've done. Yeah, just give us
five subplots, not subplots.
Just to access of you know that
set title, so we'll just give it
a title as episode rewards. So
what how does the reward change
in each episode we have plotted
let's plot that episode rewards.
Now let's do reward the score
moving score average equal to NP
dot convolve. We will plot a
colored graph in lieu np dot
array E and V dot return Q dot
satin so we'll flatten it to dot
Latin comma np dot once
and let's do more is equal to
valid and let's do rolling
length divided by rolling this
will be for every 500 iterations
we're doing this now this is
completed let's do x of zero dot
dot array range then
the word moving average
the moving average of the reward
now what I will be doing is I
will be putting it against the
reward moving average to that
value. The value here so we are
going to plot it now let's do
excess of one two is the y axis
got set title. So lengths
this is done let's do length
underscore Moving underscore
will be our variable that can be
the same way to a carnival
within do np dot Cornwalls. So
I'll explain to you why we use
the Commonwealth method as well
we need to do a blanket dot
plugin, then we need to do np
dot once. Rolling and again and
mod is equal to same so instead
of valid we'll do same now it's
to the window same close the
brackets, divide this by rolling
in
not clot length training, moving
average three out only ever
talked about training error.
Score moving average comma,
training underscore underscore
knowing no score. Loop PLT dot
tight layout
basically, I've completed the
training or visualizing of the
training parameters and how the
graph looks like. So what I'll
do is I'll just wait for the
training to complete and then
I'll explain to you the graph.
So the training is complete. Now
let's look at the different
parameters that we have plotted.
So they have three different
types of charts. Let's
understand each one of them. So
first one we have is episode
rewards. So the episode rewards
in our case of solving
Blackjack, and episode is a can
be defined as a game of
blackjack played from start to
finish. And the episode rewards
is a total sum of the rewards
obtained during that game, it
could be the sum of the numbers
of wins and losses. And we can
add any bonuses or penalties for
certain actions. So as you can
see, for each episode, there is
a very drastic change in the
rewards. So basically, this is
very interesting to watch that
it is not a flatline, basically,
we do not have any rangebound
moment between it just just too
volatile, just keep changing it
this is very interesting to
watch. So now let's look at the
episode lens combat which is
plotted against each episode. So
basically, this is one complete
sequence of playing a hand
taking a hit or a stand and
receiving the result. Now the
length of an episode would
depend on the rules of the game,
the number of players and other
factors. So in our game, it
could be just two player, but
you can have more number of
players as well. And in a game
of blackjack you could consist
of it would consist of a single
hand or multiple hands with
different lengths of each
episode. So basically, you can
see, in our case, it would be
more than one only. But it
doesn't go over two. So
basically everybody will find in
between 1.4 1.3 basically 1.3
and 1.4. So each episode is just
between 1.3 and 1.4. That is
also very interesting to watch.
Let's look at the training
error. The training error is a
measure of how well our model is
performing on the training data.
Now in our context of solving
blackjack using Kulani. The
training error would be
difference between the expected
value of the Q function and the
actual Q values obtained during
the training. The goal of Q
learning is to minimize this
error and converge to optimal Q
values that maximize the
expected reward. A high training
error indicates that the model
is not learning effectively. And
adjustments may be needed to
divert the motoring data. So as
you can see at around 3000
around 3000 This is pretty good.
Our training error is pretty
low. Now after 3000 goes pretty
high. So that's it now we are
done with our training of the
blackjack agent. And we have
successfully solved the
blackjack game using the Q
learning algorithm. Now let's
quickly revise all the things
that we have learned while we
solve when we started solving
that chapter. So we started with
the reinforcement learning
basics. Then I also explained to
you the role of an agent, what
exactly constitutes an
environment, what each action
is? And how do we keep track of
each each state that the agent
is currently in. Then we also
learned about the observation
aspect, and also how we use
rewards to keep track of a
successful step and also give
penalty to the agent when it
makes a wrong step. So
basically, we have covered that,
then I'll also explain to you
the real world use cases of
reinforcement learning. We saw
basically there is robotics game
playing autonomous driving
personalized recommendations.
Then we started by with the
gymnasium libraries basically,
it gives us a collection of
environments that can be used to
test and develop reinforcement
learning algorithms. So here we
have made use of the blackjack
environment. Then we started
with the setting, then we
started the setup for the
gymnasium environment. Also,
I've walked you through all the
processes that we need to
successfully solve any problems.
This is true for any
reinforcement learning problem.
Then I also explained to you the
main concepts of open air
gymnasium. To be started with
observation and action spaces
episode, what is the wrapper
benchmark. Now we start with the
introduction to the blackjack
game, basically are the basic
rules. The game is paired with
one or more decks of tender
playing cards. Each player is
dealt two cards and the data is
also dealt two cards with one
card facedown. The value of each
card is determined by its rank.
It says Can we work 111 face
cards, that is kings, queens and
jacks, what 10 and all other
face cards are worth at face
value. And basically, we have
the option to hit and take
additional cards to improve our
hand or stand and give the
current time the dealer must hit
until there were and as a value
of 17 or more. If a player's
hand goes over 21 They bust and
they lose the game. If the
dealer's hand goes over 21 the
player wins the game. If neither
the player nor the dealer busts
the hand with the highest total
value that is less than or equal
to 21 wins the game. So, this is
an example road. Now we have
learned about the action space,
the observation space, the
starting space, what the rewards
and what constitutes an episode
and how does an episode end. So,
we have the termination
conditions here. Now, we have
started with the solving of
blackjack, I also introduced you
to a very good book that is
reinforcement learning and
introduction by Richard Sutton
and Andrew Bartow. Basically,
this is the the summary of the
book. Now, we started with the
installing of the So, basically
we have started with the
installing of all of the all the
libraries that we need for the
tutorial. So there is
matplotlib, NumPy, Seabourn then
we started with our import
statements. So, we have imported
all the libraries that we need.
Now here is where we have
created our logic we want
environment then we have set the
environment and started with the
first observation then we have
observation tuple basically this
is the tuple. Now then, we start
executing the actions, we have
the next step reward terminated
state truncated state and the
info. Basically, this is the
step. Now, we have used the
epsilon greedy strategy to solve
blackjack. So, what is the
epsilon greedy strategy? In this
strategy, the agent takes an
action that is either the best
action based on the current
policy with a probability of one
minus epsilon or a random action
with a probability of epsilon.
This approach balances the
exploitation of the current base
policy with exploration of new
policies, which can lead to
better rewards in the long run.
Basically, this was the epsilon
greedy strategy that we use. So
I explained to you the what is
the Q value. So, this is the
class for our black jacket, we
have all the methods we have to
get actually meant that date
method. Now we started with the
training. So we have set up some
hyper parameters here, I also
explained in detail what each
parameter does, so you can just
play around with these. Now we
start with the training loop, we
have the episode, we have
created a number of episodes.
Now we what we do is while not
done, we play the episode. And
basically this is an area where
I got to we started with the
rolling length.
So this is the plotting of the
graphs that we did here, too.
This was the code for that. And
also I explained to you the
URL, what are all the graphs
that we have plotted here? So
now we've solved logic using key
learning. Also. Now let's look
at some other methods that we
can solve that check. So the
first one is Monte Carlo method.
Monte Carlo is a more model free
method that learns from
experience. In the context of
blackjack Monte Carlo methods
involves playing the game
several times, and in keeping
track of the rewards obtained
for each action, the agent then
updates its value function based
on the average of the rewards
obtained for each state action
pair. Monte Carlo methods are
suitable for problem like
episode tasks like blackjack, so
you can use him NASM and try
this approach as well. Now let's
look at the other approach.
temporal difference method. It
is another model free method
that learns from experience. In
the TD learning the agent
updates its value function based
on the difference between the
predicted and the actual reward.
TD methods are suitable for
problems with continuous tasks
like blackjack. Q learning is
something that we've already
solved blackjack. But let's just
quickly revise what Q learning
you're learning is a model free
reinforcement learning algorithm
that learns to optimal policy.
By updating its Q values for
each state pair. The agents
selects the action with the
highest Q value for a given
state. Q learning is suitable
for problems with finite states
and actions like blackjack. The
fourth method that we have is
deep Q networks. So basically we
will be solving so in the next
example, we will be solving card
poll problem that is like an
Atari game where you have to
balance the card poll, and we'll
be using deep Q networks. So I
also explained in detail what
are the deep Q networks. So
let's look at the brief. Deep Q
networks combined reinforcement
learning with deep neural
networks, DQ NS learn the
optimal policy by approximating
the Q values using a deep neural
network. DQ ns are suitable for
problems with high dimensional
state spaces like image based
games to it like an image from
these are suitable for image
based games. Now, the fifth
example that we have is actor
critic example. Actor critic is
a model based reinforcement
learning algorithm that uses the
two networks an actor and a
critic, the actor network
selects the actions while the
critic network evaluates the
actions taken by the actor,
actor critic is suitable for
problems with continuous action
spaces like that gap. So these
are all the different approaches
that you can use to solve
blackjack. And I highly
encourage you all to use
gymnasium and try these
approaches. So you will find you
will, you will have to use some
math for that. Also, you will
find that online as well. But
these are the different
approaches that you can use.
So now let's go to another
example where we'll be using the
environment of the carpool. So
now let's understand what what
what is the carpool environment,
and then we understand about
deep Q networks. So in the
carpool environment, we have an
agent that can decide to actions
moving the cart, right or woman
the cart left, right or left, so
the poll attached to it stays
upright. So as you can see in
this clip, we have to balance
the poll. And these are can be
random actions, so it could just
tilt left twice, or it could go
to the left five times, and it
could go to the right one. So we
need to have all the
possibilities covered here. You
can find more information about
the environment at the gymnasium
website. So I have also linked
the website link here. Now let's
look in detail. As the agent
observes the current state of
the environment and chooses an
action, the environment
transitions to a new state, and
also returns a reward that
indicates the consequences of
the action in this task reward
plus one for every incremental
time step. And the environment
terminates if the pole of the
pole falls over too far, or the
cart moves over 2.4 units away
from the center. So basically,
we do not have a lot we cannot
allow the pole to fall 2.4 units
away from the center. And for
every incremental time step, we
have pressed one reward, so we
have to maximize the number of
times you can balance this
cardboard. This means meter
performing scenarios will run
for longer duration,
accumulating larger return. The
Cardpool task is designed so
that the inputs to the agent are
for real values, representing
the environmental state
position, velocity, etc. We take
these four inputs without any
scaling and pass them through a
small fully connected network
with two outputs one for each
action. The network is trained
to predict the expected value
for each action given the input
state. The action with the
highest expected value is then
chosen. So now let's look in
detail at how We can implement
this network as well. Now let's
look at all the methods that
we'll be using from Python. So
the first is the neural
networks, which is imported
using torch.nn. Now, in general,
this module provides tools for
building neural networks. It
includes a wide range of layer
type, wide range of layer types,
such as fully connected layers,
convolutional layers, and
recurrent layers, as well as
activation functions and loss
functions. Now let's look at in
perspective of a DQ n, the
torch.nn model is used to define
our neural network architecture.
Now let's look at the other
method that is the optimization
method. Now this module provides
a range of optimization
algorithm for training neural
networks. It includes classic
optimization algorithms, such as
stochastic gradient descent, as
well as more advanced algorithms
like Adam and RMS Pro. But let's
look at in context of the DQ N,
we'll be using towards the
optimization module to optimize
our neural network weights. Next
is torch dot auto grad, this
model now, this model in the
context of DQ n is used to
compute gradients during back
propagation. This module
provides automatic
differentiation functionality
which is essential for training
neural networks. Why am back
propagation, it enables patterns
to automatically compute
gradients of a loss function
with respect to all the
parameters of the network
allowing optimization algorithms
to adjust the parameters in
order to minimize the loss. Now
let's import the modules that we
need. So the first is the
gymnasium classic control. Let's
import that. Basically that
convert that contains a model
that we need to cut pole v1
model let's install that pip
install Nazeem classic
underscore control this is the
name so now let's also import
all the other methods that we'll
need so let's import import NASM
as gym mat. So basically these
are all the inbuilt models
method inbuilt is doing random
randomization what method is
matplotlib this charting library
plot lib it's used for making
charts there's import map plot
dot pie plot as PLT I think one
of the most common code lines in
Python code named tuple and that
so basically we'll be using
these data structures to manage
the training maker tools input
count meter reading this now
let's import all the torch
models for torch torch.nn has an
OPCOM OPCOM import.nn dot
functional functional f Now
let's also create our
environment so we need this will
be gym dot make card poll
click poll new one now also
let's set the inline setting for
matplotlib. In AD lib.net I
think I forgot to import this
little read that quote because I
think we can directly make it in
Leno's in collab. If we end
Google collab, we want pyplot.to
be plotted as inline. So that
will be displayed below the cell
if is IPython so basically this
is Google collab again from
ipython. Input display because
we need the display to display
the charts do PLT that ion.
Also, if you do not have a GPU,
we can just add a condition as
well. And if you do have a GPU,
then we can increase the
training. So let's set the
variable. If we have a GPU, this
CUDA is the art.cuda.so.
Basically, this is the method to
understand if we do have a GPU
available. And you can just go
to settings in tools, you need
to go to settings, and Google
editor in the run time, I think
you need to send it around. So
it will change and time time.
And you can just add a GPU or so
I will do that, I'll do that as
well. So it will basically give
us a lot more computing power.
So now we've completed the basic
in code where we have imported
all the libraries that we will
need. Now let's look at another
concept that is very important
in this in this example, or to
solve cardboard. So now let's
look at replay memory. So what
is replay memory, it is a
technique used in D enforcement
learning to store and manage the
experience of an agent during
training. The idea is to store
the agents experiences as a
sequence of state action reward
next, state tuples. So
basically, we have just four
values, which are collected as
the agent interacts with the
environment. During training,
these experiences are used to
update the agents policy and
value function. So basically,
this is the we collect all the
actions performed by our agent.
Now let's look at what the
importance of replay memory. The
replay memory allows the agent
to learn from past experiences
by randomly sampling a batch of
experiences from the memory
buffer, rather than just
learning from the most recent
experience. So it's like the, so
we instead of just learning from
our recent experience, we take a
sample of all the past
experiences and make a decision
based on that. This helps us to
reduce the correlation between
subsequent experiences, which
can improve the stability and
convergence of the learning
algorithm. In addition, by
storing experiences in a buffer,
the agent can reuse past
experiences to update his policy
and value function multiple
times, which can further improve
learning efficiency. The replay
memory is typically implemented
as a fixed size buffer or queue
that stores the most recent
experiences. When the buffer is
full. New experiences overwrite
the oldest experiences in the
buffer. During training, a batch
of experiences is randomly
sampled from the buffer and used
to update the agent's policy and
value function. This process is
repeated iteratively until the
agent converges to an optimal
policy. So basically, this is an
example it's a basic thing. It's
a very basic concept, we store
all of the training data until
the queue is full. And the
buffer memory that we have will
keep using it as we go ahead.
Where does the concept now let's
look at how we'll use the
concept of replay memory in
order to implement our DQ n
algorithm. So what we'll do is,
let's understand that so we'll
store the transition that the
agent observed, allowing us to
reuse this iterator by sampling
from it randomly the transitions
that build up a batch or D
correlated, it has been shown
that this greatly stabilizes and
improve the deployment training
procedure. Now let's also
understand how we implement this
in code. So we'll have two
classes. One is the first will
be transition class it is a
named tuple representing a
single transition in our
environment. Basically, this is
our sample input. So this will
be represent one state and
essentially map state action
pairs to the next state reward
result with the state being the
screen dividends image as
described later on. Next will be
the replay class, a cyclic
buffer of bounded size that
holds the transitions observed
decently. It also implements a
dot sample method for selecting
a random batch of transitions
pertaining. Let's implement our
replay memory class. So the
first will be the transition
state that we have which is a
tuple which is the named tuple
by the name of transition and
then we'll have a state action
next
We have recently this is our
condition tuple. Now let's also
create our class, which is the
deeply mini class. So it will be
a class we call replay memory,
then object. Let's do def
underscore underscore in it,
self, comma, capacity. And then
we'll have self dot memory. So
basically this will return the
full memory buffer. So it is
equal to that. I don't know how
you pronounce it, but I
pronounce it as that it could be
called as DQ also, depending on
the accent here, max length is
equal to capacity. So basically,
this is our max length. After
that it it will overflow and
then we'll reset it so we'll use
one transition into this memory
was here it says no memory will
have self comma REM sleep are
some arguments as well.
Basically, it is also comment
save so I think it is double
save a transition save raishin.
Memory node append transition
star arcs
Okay, so basically this will
append to our memory buffer,
let's create another method of
the sample. This method will
help us sample our buffer
remember, before memory cells
come up bad size. So we have a
capacity and the batch size. So
it the capacity could be 50 and
the batch will be 10. So this is
how the there's no return.
random sample. Okay. Still not
memory. Let's size
define underscore underscore
length may give us the length of
the buffer at any point.
Return length or size but
memory. So yeah, I think we have
done it completed. Let's also
look through the code again. So
we have defined the transition
tuple and replay memory class.
Now we have fulfils your state
action next state. I think I
need to do that this year
awards. I think it is rewarding.
And we will have other class as
well. So we'll have the push
method. This method takes in a
state which is state action next
ID tuple as input and creates a
transition object from it and
append it to the deck. If the
deck is already at maximum
capacity, the oldest element in
the deck is removed. So this is
how the append method works.
Let's look at the sample method.
This method randomly samples a
batch of batch size, which is
the batch size parameters that
were passed experiences from the
deck and returns them as a list.
So this is the sampling method.
Let's look at the length method.
This method returns the current
length of the deck. Now let's
understand the DQ n algorithm in
detail and how we use the
algorithm to solve the Cardpool
problem. So it is a
reinforcement learning algorithm
that uses deep neural networks
to approximate the Q function in
a Q learning algorithm. So in
short, basically it is that but
we need to understand the steps
involved to solve the Cardpool
environment. Let's look at that
as well. First we need to
initialize the Q network with
random weights. The second is
sample and action using an
epsilon greedy policy.
Basically, we have covered this
in our blackjack tutorial, which
selects the action with the
highest Q value with probability
one minus epsilon and the random
action with a probability
epsilon. Execute the action and
observe the next state and
reward. Store the experience to
Built in a replay buffer, so we
have implemented the class
already sample a mini batch of
experiences from the replay
buffer, we've already created
the method for that, compute the
Q target values for the mini
batch using the Bellman
equation. So basically, this is
how we calculate the t Q value
I'll explain to you when we read
the code, compute the Q values
for the mini batch using the
current Q network. So we'll have
that value. And we just need to
compute the Q value for that.
Compute the loss between the Q
values and the Q target values,
and update the Q network
parameters using gradient
descent. And we'll keep doing
these steps until we reach
convergence or we reach a fixed
number of episodes. So I will
explain in detail what what we
are going to do to the end of
the cardboard. The DQ n
algorithm uses a target network
to stabilize the training
process. The target network is a
copy of the Q network that is
updated less frequently than the
Q network. This helps to prevent
the Q values from oscillating
during training. So that's what
happened in our budget. When we
are solving that check. In
Cardpool environment, the DTN
algorithm learns to balance the
port on the cart by moving the
cart left or right. The queue
network takes the state of the
environment as inputs and
outputs the Q values for each
possible action, the DQ n
algorithm learns to maximize the
Q values by updating the Q
network parameters using
gradient descent. With enough
training, the DQ n algorithm can
learn to balance the pole on the
cart for extended periods of
time. So basically, this is all
the steps in what and how we are
going to solve the Godbole.
Example, we are going to balance
out the card pool for a very
extended period of time. Now
let's go to our cue network. So
let's take some notes here.
So far model will be a
convolutional neural network. If
you take the difference between
the current and the previous
screen patches, it will have two
outputs representing Q, S comma
left and q s comma right, where
s is the input to the network.
That, in effect, the network is
trying to predict the expected
return of taking each action
given the current input. So
basically, this is our cue
network. This is the full
implementation will have two
outputs. And the network is
trying to predict the expected
return of taking each action
given the current input. Now
let's implement our DQ N class.
Let's add the class here. That's
right class, the Q n and n n dot
module.
So let's do def, underscore,
underscore init, underscore
underscore, self comma n,
underscore observations. Comma
and underscore actions. So I'll
explain to you in detail that
just complete the class first,
and then we'll read the comments
as well. So it will be very easy
to understand. We self dot
underscore underscore in it.
Self thought we left three
layers, let's do all the three
layers here to three, the equal
to and then thought linear and
underscore observations 128. So
we have sizes and 128. Let's do
that. We'll the next one will be
128 by 128. This is how it will
be now and the other one will be
the exactly the opposite of this
will be 128 by the number of
actions comma and underscore
options. So we've implemented
the new folding in it consulted.
Let's go and define our method.
That is the forward method. And
we have to do self dot causes
comma x and x is equal to f dot
value self dot layer 1x And then
we have the layer 2x. And then
we'll return the cell got layer
3x. So we'll basically go to
three layers what the code now
let's understand what are we
trying to do here? So we have
the cue network which is Mighty
perceptron, so let's just keep
writing it down yet mighty per
mighty layer or scepter on any
point, you can just use
perceptron with three layers.
So, this is what we are trying
to achieve here. Now, we have
what the input is it is a
tensor. So, the what will be the
input, so it will be a tensor of
the size and underscore
observation is our size
which is single this is what we
passed here. Actions is our
input to the network this is
basically the state input that
is the state of the environment,
state of environment to the
network. So, we have the fully
connected layer with 120
neurons, followed by a value
activation function. I'll also
explain like why we're using
that the second layer is also a
fully connected layer with 128
neurons and a ReLU activation
function. The final layer is a
fully connected layer with an
actions where an action
represents the number of
possible actions in the
environment, which represents a
certain number of possible
actions.
environment now, let's look at
the forward method what we have
implemented here. So, if you
take the input as the tensor
that is the X tensor, as it
passed through the first layer
of the network using the value
activation function, pass, take
input, we pass to two or three
layers on the network when.
Basically, this is what we're
trying to do here. And what we
are also trying to do is, so,
we'll pass it to the state to
the network. And what we will
get this, the output is the
corresponding neuron in the
final layer. So, when you pass
here, we'll get an output we'll
pass it to the next year. And in
the third layer, we finally
return. So and what will happen
here, so during training, the Q
network is updated using the
Bellman equation that we have
discussed already to minimize
the mean squared error between
the target values and the Q
values. Yeah, so let's look at
that. Now let's look at the
training of our DQ n. So what
we'll do is we'll have a Q
network, which is updated using
the Bellman equation to minimize
the mean squared error between
the predicted Q values and the
target Q values. The Target Q
values are computed using the Q
network but with the weights
frozen and not updated during
the current iteration of
training. This, this helps to
stabilize the training process
and prevent the network from
overfitting to the data. Okay,
now let's look at all the other
parameters that we will be have.
Or I can say parameters and
utilities as well. So first,
we'll have select action, it
will select an action according
to the epsilon greedy policy, we
have again covered this in the
blackjack tutorial. In the back
when we were solving blackjack
using toolani. We simply put
will sometimes use our model for
choosing the action. And
sometimes we'll just sample one
uniformly. So there is no steps
for that. But we will see how we
can do that. Now, the
probability of choosing a random
action we start at EPS start and
will decay exponentially towards
EPs and EPS decay controls the
rate of decay. So, basically,
this is the set of we do not
have any particular target
value. So as we go along, the
values will keep changing. And
we have to decide whether we
want to take a random action or
we want to take from the action
that we have on the board. Next
we have plot durations. It is a
helper for plotting the
durations of episodes, along
with an average over the last
100 episodes. The measure used
in the official evaluations. The
plot will be underneath the cell
containing the main training
loop and will update after every
episode. So we'll plot this
training durations as well.
Let's now go to the code. So
let's implement
all the parameters that we are
going to need so I'll have pad
size, that size equal to 1.8
comma You can do zero point. So
I'll also explain like this,
just complete all the parameters
for
your start. Start is equal to
0.9, we have EPS, and you will
do 0.05. So basically this is
when we will end. This is our
epsilon and lbps decay rate,
which is going to be 1000. And
we have the tall, which is the
one who is 0.005. And our
learning rate is going to be one
e raise to minus four. Yeah,
this is our this is what is
going to be Yep. Now, let's read
the comments as well, what is
going to be the batch size
number of transitions sampled
from the labor force
it is grandma this is what is
the discount factor as
mentioned, we will do the
discount factor. So what is
going to be the EPS third
quarter
is the final value of episode
yesterday the starting value of
the epsilon basically, we can
just write it next to it as
well. So we don't have to waste
the time just writing now, it is
a starting value of epsilon.
Let's look at the EPS. And this
is the ending value of final
value of epsilon. Let's look at
the EPS became in EPS API
educate controls to equal
mediaspace.
controls the rate of exponential
decay
decay of epsilon higher means a
slower rate. So first we'll
start with a very slow rate. And
then we'll keep improving on our
learning rates. So there is
going to me higher means slower
and slower decay. Let's look at
our this as well is that is the
update rate of the target
network? What is tau? Tau is the
network. And what is going to be
the LRT it is going to be a
learning rate. So this is going
to be the atom optimizer. So
let's look at now what is this
is the perfect time to
understand about the atom W
optimizer, Atom optimizer and
atom optimizer. So basically now
let's look at the atom
optimizer. So basically we've
defined it you're eliminating
all these parameters and
eliminating it for the atom
optimizer. So this is the
learning rate for the RM
optimizer. So Adam, adaptive
moment estimation is a popular
optimization algorithm that is
commonly used in deep learning.
It is an extension of stochastic
gradient descent. If you do not
know about that, it's okay, you
can still watch the rest of the
video, which is the most basic
optimization algorithm used to
train neural networks. The main
idea behind Adam is to combine
the advantages of two other
optimization techniques, add a
grad and RMS problem. So if you
do not know about that as well,
it's okay. In the DQ n
algorithm. We use Adam optimizer
to update the weights of our
neural network based on the
gradients of the loss function
with respect to the parameters,
so we'll define our loss
function as one minus epsilon.
Specifically, we use the Adam W
optimizer which is a variant of
the atom. So we have defined it
here which is a variant of the
atom that also incorporates
weight decay regularization.
weight decay helps prevent
overfitting by adding a penalty
to the last function that is
proportional to the magnitude of
the weights. By adding this
penalty the optimizer encourages
the network to learn simpler and
more generalizable
representations. The learning
rate is a hyper parameter that
controls the step size taken
during optimization. It is an
important parameter to tune as a
high learning rate can cause the
optimizer to overshoot the
optimal weights and lead to
divergence while a low learning
rate can result in slow
convergence and getting stuck in
a local minima. In DQ n
algorithm, we set the learning
rate to one e raise to minus
one. So basically, this is what
this is why we're going to use
that optimizer. So we don't get
stuck in a local minima. So, we
need to control the learning
rate. And for the content to the
learning rate, we need that and
W optimizer. In summary, the
Adam W optimizer is is a widely
is a widely used optimization
algorithm in deep learning. And
it is used in DQ n algorithm to
update the weights of the neural
network based on the gradients
of the loss function with
respect to the parameters, while
also incorporating weight decay
regularization. So this is the
very critical role played by
Adam W optimizer. Now, let's so
now we will learn about the atom
optimizer. Now let's learn about
now let's read the code for the
other two other utilities that
are pending. So the first
variable that we have is the end
actions, this is going to be NV
dot action, the action space. So
basically, this is going to be
the action space of the carpool
environment. So let me just keep
it up, let's just keep writing
the number the comments as well.
Number of actions from them
action space. Also, now let's do
that net number of
state observations, which is
going to be state comma info.
So, basically, this is going to
be that tuple that we talked
about the content all the
information related to the
current state, the current
state that we are in and of the
reasons is going to be length of
state. Now let's create our
policy net, which is going to be
a class it is going to be an
instance of the DQ N class. We
have this Ruby and underscore
operations comma and underscore
actions not to device specific
devices that what we have set up
to target net as well. Targeted
net is equal to same thing. Now
let's load the state
target dot score net not load
underscore state underscore the
policy this coordinate got state
I think it is policy and I
understand the state.
Now let's complete the optimizer
so I'll just come back and
explain to you everything is
just complete the optimizer also
now basically, we this is going
to be the torch method OChem but
we added W we discussed about
atom W I also explained to you
the atom W optimizer and our
atom optimizer is going to be
policy underscore net dot
parameters. Okay parameters
needed we have already defined
small error is equal to capital
error. Total Error is defined
here.
one equals two minus code from
AMS guard AMS grad, so like
listening to you what this means
as well.
Let's complete the code memory
we'll be taking the last 10,000
episodes for our memory. Do
replay. Memory 10,000 We passed
in to our buffer size is going
to be 10,000. Let's define the
steps done as well. With me,
this is where we currently are.
Okay, let's let's go ahead and
just complete all the methods
let's do the Select action as
well. Basically this is going to
be the method that will help us
select any action. So if I have
a state, it will just tell us
which methods are and
steps underscore done sample is
equal to random sample I think
it is wrong it is random not
random
and with the PPS on the score
threshold is equal to EPS score
and plus EPS underscore start we
have defined all these
parameters before VPS the scope
and into we have to divide it by
offering when you go to the next
line so with me goes less
mad not mad dot exponent of
minus one towards star off steps
done by up to K yeah this is
going to be the equation
and then let's do steps done
once we're done with this little
loop do steps than possible will
rent payment from those sample
to them UPS underscore threshold
and do with torch.no Grad so
basically we'll be doing that
we'll do T dot max one minute
and the largest column of each
row
this column value
okay what does it mean this is a
row we have the second column
second column on max
next up where Max element was
was fun so, we pick action with
largest yeah so, we need to like
we need to optimize for the
larger what will basically this
is what we are going to do
expected reward let's do return
policy score net state dot max
not view one comma one now we
need to do the as of this as
well is the ELS
dot pensar en v dot actions so
we'll just return the action
space
action underscore space dot
sample response. So basically
this is our we're going to do is
we'll see if we want to take a
sample one already to keep
continuing the path that we are
on. Do that okay, now with the
device is equal to device and
command D type call sheet.com
Okay, so I'll explain to you all
these utilities let's just
complete all the methods while
we're at it. So does equal to
Episode underscore durations
Okay, So what we'll do is just
go over all the methods that we
completed. So, the N actions is
the number of actions in the
environments, no environments
action space will be the gym
environments, state comma info
are obtained by the setting the
environment and observations is
the number of features in the
state. Let's just drill down as
well in the state let's do the
target net is initiate with the
same weight as policy net Okay.
target net initialized
with the same weight as policy
net then we have the optimizer
which is not an optimizer Adam W
optimizer optimizer is LM W
optimizer. Adam W. Normally
optimizer pytorch with the
learning rate and other hyper
parameters specified earlier. So
we use it to optimize the
weights.
Use to optimize weights, we
already passed all the
parameters that we need.
Let's go to the memory. So the
memory is an instance of the
replay memory, and it has a
capacity of 10,000. Okay, so
let's do a site wide recall you
can store
intense experiences which will
be for training for training
just ever done. Because it is it
is used to keep track of
the steps number of texts keep
track of number of texts taken
by the date. We're going to
start with we're going to start
with zero. Now let's understand
the step action method as well.
So it takes the current state as
input, let's just write down and
code this current state and
returns an action so it could be
either that the action is it
could be selected by choosing
the action with the highest Q
value. So this is going to be
the ISP value. Or it could be
that we have taken a random so
how we're going to decide so
we're going to decide by this
expression. So we had discussed
earlier that we're going to be
calculating the threshold value
and if there was a sample within
the threshold value, and we have
no grad then we go to the
maximum or too high SQL that we
have that we find or we take the
random random approach. So
basically this is going to be
the envy that action or sample
everything the sample and the
device will be either a CPU or a
GPU in our game it is the GPU
that we have defined earlier.
And last we have episode
durations interviews to keep
track of the duration we can
often each episode
so now let's also complete the
plot durations method which will
plot all the duration of each.
So net is taken by the agent we
have shows multiple calls. Start
with the PLT dot trigger. Mainly
we're going to plot we're going
to be using biplot here when
durations underscore t is equal
to torch dot tensor. We have the
episode underscore duration.
Format D type is equal to torch
dot float. If so underscore
result The PLT dot title wizard,
we're going to be keeping the
title and result as a rule that
we have also basically the first
time we change the title and
then we'll plot the crosshairs
so that now training painting
graphs
PLT dot x, x level is going to
be episode and then we have PLT
dot y label, which is duration.
Then we have PLT dot plot
durations. Obviously, we think
this munition under different
durations might have taken not
NumPy will convert it to the
numpy array. And then we'll take
100 Episode averages. So let's
start it on. First, let's do
that clip length
greater than 100 doesn't equal
200.
Then means durations underscore
t naught unfold zero to slice it
and we'll take the mean and then
we'll take the other viewers
what little means is equal to
Torstar cat it's going to be
towards our cat towards third
zeros 99 And then we have the
means then we have PLT dot plot
dot NumPy let's add a pause when
you have PLT dot 0.001 pause so
that plots are updated. And then
we if we have a display so
basically I just write it down
so that it works on all the
environments. If we just run it
in your local VS code also it
should work right. So it will be
show underscore results display
dot display dot DCF and display
display dot here or
wait is equal to
display dot display PLT dot GCF.
So I'll explain to you what all
these plots mean. We're done. So
we have completed the method.
Let's now go and write some
comments. So but it basically it
will be very clear for all of
you. So this method is used to
visualize visualize the training
progress of the DQ N
basically, this is the method
here. Now first we'll create a
tensor from Episode durations.
So basically this is the keep
track of the lengths of
intuition. And then we'll get
into using matplotlib. And if we
have the show result as true
then we'll label label it as
dessert or as it will be
training. And the x axis is
labeled as episodes the Y is
labeled as duration. And we have
a function that is called we
have a variable that is called
durations underscore t is a blue
line and overlays With a red
line that shows 100 Episode
moving average of the durations,
so let's just write it down. So
the 100
moving average of the durations
Yep, so while we wait for just a
second so that the plots are
updated it'll come in real time.
And if you have a Jupyter
Notebook, then we'll use can use
this method as we'll just use a
normal method so now let's start
our training loop. So, let's
create our optimized model here
called model from spaces if
length
match network size then return
we do not need to optimize at
the start then we have the
transition when we take a memory
that sample basically this is
the sampling we will do the
sampling
okay, then we have the batch
match is equal to transition so,
visibly this looks a little bit
complicated, but I'll explain to
you like why we do this
basically we transpose the batch
and it will convert the batch
array of transitions to
transition a batch or is it
converts batch or a batch of
transitions to trans transition
of batteries
now, let's compute the mask of
non final states 30 being non
underscore final underscore mask
equal to torch dot insert then
we have that tuple do map
iterator than the continue
number is says not none
match.com device
this is done so let's write down
what this method will do what
we're planning to do, we're
going to compute
our mask off non final states
and the batch limits okay and
the final state will be where
the simulation and basically
that means that
let's do I think we have to
provide a parameter can be D
type SQL to towards that Boolean
now let's do the non final next
states
recall that cat as far as that's
not next step
is not null. Then we have the
state underscore batch equal to
torch dot cat batch dot state
And we have the action but the
action bets New Order batch
Yeah, this is bad dot action
this is bad got reward
so now let's compute the Q value
now state score action let's
call values equal to policy net
basically this is the policy
that we're planning to use
policy net state school beds not
the other one comma action
we'll compute the key value here
it's now compute the next state
values also. Next underscore
state which will be the final
state if it is ending then it
will be zero in case the finest
gets the state was the final
state will be taught not zero
match score size comma device is
equal to device us now with no
no torch or that no grand
do next underscore state
underscore values non underscore
final mask SQL to target net it
looks a little bit complicated
but trust me when I explained to
you after writing the code they
were pretty clear what's missing
there looks code looks
intimidating but what we tend to
do is pretty simple got Max one
of zero now let's also compute
the expected value
expected underscore state
underscore action value
I think we I forgot that yeah we
need to do this first you can do
this first cannot
underscore values equal to next
state values values to gamma
let's see what we what that
about losses well I'll explain
to you what police teams losses
criterion
is equal to n dot mood one loss
that's the name and also the
call to
state score action score I use
expected the school state school
action expected sports score
action score values squeeze one.
Now let's optimize
the optimizer dot basically our
query and the way to do
optimizer dot zero underscore
grad loss dot backward
is in place so it must be
looking like It's pretty tough
but trust me I'll explain to the
Medicare then dot dot utils not
clip grad value add value
underscore policy not net that
parameters commander
then verse will keep the value
now let's do optimizer dot
now, let's look at this. So,
first we check if this is a mini
batch, so, we have the Optimize
method right. So, this is deep Q
learning that is working what we
already know. So well let's
check what we do. So first we
replay memory. So, first we
check if the replay memory
contains enough samples to fill
up a mini batch let's write it
down if check if we have enough
samples for you if you do not
then return nothing then do
nothing okay and then let's
transition. So, first then we
what do we do is we take many
bytes extract
extract extract I mean us me
myself transitions from Epson
comma reward comma next step
from that
now then also what we do is we
calculated calculate the
expected Q value and it is the
sum of the immediate reward. So,
basically we have it here
too, we have the gamma as well I
cannot see grandma Yeah, so,
basically just search for Yeah,
this is where we do the expected
state calculation. So, what we
do is okay good calculate the
expected Q value Expected Q
value you value for each
transition using the target
network basically we have
created our neural network here.
Now, if you do not know how to
create a basic neural network,
no issues so, basically it is
the sum of the immediate reward
and the discounted Q value of
the next state. Okay, now under
this contract is controlled by
the gamma. Okay, now, let's see
the function. Now what we'll do
is we'll calculate the q value
predicted by the Policy Network
for each transition. And we'll
also select the queue
corresponding to the action
taken by the agent. So,
basically, what we are doing
here, we are also selecting now,
we need to calculate the hover
loss as well. The upper loss is
a smooth approximation of the
mean squared error loss and is
less sensitive to outliers. So,
we need to be less than smooth.
What is our loss it is a smooth
approximation. We do not
understand how the loss knows us
you can just look it up. But
it's a pretty good metric for
calculating data loss. Listen
that
basically, this is our losses.
And now finally we back
propagate now to the Quality
Network and update the
parameters using the Adam W
optimizer. And we also have
clipped it to a maximum of 100
To prevent the exploding
gradient problem, so
maximum value is equal to under
to prevent exploding gradient
problem so now, let's go on to
the main loop now maintaining
loop. So we have completed the
training part of it now we need
to create,
we need to start implementing
the algorithm. Let's do that
now. So what we'll do is if
torch dot CUDA, basically, I'm
just making the code in such a
way that if you do not have a
GPU, you can use this code, you
don't have to make any changes.
So then you need to make number
underscore episodes, you can
just keep it 50.
And also, if it is available,
then I will keep it somewhere
else. I'll do it
now let's loop over the episodes
for I underscore episode in
range of number of episodes
to date, so I don't I think you
all know what this does is
really set the environment and
get the current state and the
all the information that we
need. Yeah, let's just write it
down again. Visualize the
environment. Get state to state
is equal to torch the tensor
state comma D type is equal to
call that float 32. Comma device
is equal to device and let's do
an squeeze zero. I think you all
know what we're doing here. I've
already explained it once. Let's
look let's create another loop.
Now what do we have the
encounter? Number of counter the
reaction is equal to cylinder
since we need to select an
action here. Select underscore
action false was for the first
time we do not want anything
with by the state and we want
observation. Comma, reward comma
terminated comma can get it any
other parameters that we get is
equal to NV dot step is
equal to send your items where
you could take action on items.
And then at Maker step forward,
so we'll need a new observation
they were terminated and you're
truncated well. Yeah, now let's
give the final reward is well,
we've taken a step forward now
let's
look on the reward or the tensor
reward karma device, welcome
device. And we have done is
equal to terminate it or
truncated.
And we have if Yeah, so we can
either have that we have
completed the number of steps or
that we have the card if the
card pool has fallen off 2.4
meters away from the center to
easily that could be that next
underscore state is equal to
none. As we need to do you find
the next state? We'll do that.
One next state will be we call
it a tensor
tensor observation variation
comma V type V Going to torch
dot float 32 comma device, the
call to device dot and squeeze,
zero now let's add this next
step in memory. So we can do
that using manager push, we have
created that in our class
action, we already have all this
action. Next, we have the next
video. And we have the reward.
Now store, just keep that in
comments as well store the
transition
and then move to next, let's
move to the next as well.
So basically, we move to the
next step, let's optimize the
model. Now. We have already
created the model for that, the
method for that. Now let's do
the soft update of the target
network weights. So we already
have that new target underscore
net underscore state. The score
did this mean we need to do it
for both the target and the
policy next. goal to target and
the score net dot state
underscore dict. So if you find
it pretty difficult, it's okay.
I happen to be the first time.
But when it comes into code, I
just go everything once again.
So everything becomes very
clear. For Kean policy net, I
think we have to take this one
is the policy net, that's to
training that state.
And then when to do key. The
call to policy net underscore
net underscore state underscore
of key swing into to multiplied
by the tau tau plus target net
state t. So the old value also
into one minus tau. Basically
this is what we're planning to
do now.
One minus tau is what we're
doing. Now let's see if we are
done. We are going to do a
software update. And then we are
done. Episode dot.so We are
completed one episode two, I
think I've explained to you what
is the difference between
Episode and an iteration.
Basically, an episode is the one
sequence between a start and an
end to basically in the
cardboard instance, the start
will be when we started the
initial state. And then if we
fall of 2.4 meters away from the
center, or that we have
completed the game, basically we
have achieved the maximum state
that we could we have a number
of times we could have, we could
have played this game. So this
is one, this is going to be one
one time that we are going to
play the game basically. And we
are for if you have a GPU, we're
going to do this 600 times. So
basically, we have to play this
game 600 times. There's going
durations and there's to break
out. Now let's complete it. So
finally, we have completed then
we are going to plot all the
durations. Basically what I
encourage is we can just keep
changing the number of durations
and check the results.
Basically, that is something I
want you to do. And I'm not
going to do that. I'm just going
to stick to the 600 episodes,
because I have a GPU I have and
PLT dot show
done with the cart pole
environment as well. Let's
quickly summarize everything
that we have learned. So what
the agent has to decide it has
to decide between two actions
moving the cart left or right.
So basically this is so we do a
loop here. So as you can see,
either the carpet will move left
or right and we need to balance
it out. So now I've explained
all this in detail Let's look at
all the methods that we have
imported. So, we have imported
the torch that nn which is used
for our neural network, we have
imported that thought is that
octane method, which is for
optimization imported towards an
autograph, which is for
automatic differentiation. And
also I've explained in detail
what each of this is you would
extend each of this in detail as
well. Now, we have started with
the import of the module that we
need also we have started. So,
basically we have installed it
and here we have imported all
the methods that we need, here
we have set up the environment.
And also I have also made it
such that you can run it in the
Google collab notebook as well
also in just any python script
as well. So, just accordingly,
then we have detected if CUDA is
available, which is a GPU. Now,
I have also explained to you
what is the concept of replay
memory, basically, it is a
technique used in reinforcement
learning to store and manage the
experiences of an agent during
training. So, basically, we will
make use of this, we have saved
all of the steps that the agent
takes, and use that to make a
future decisions. So we're going
to make two classes one
transition class and one replay
memory class to basically we
have to transition here and then
we have the replay memory class.
And we are going to use the DQ n
algorithm. It is a deep Q
network, which is a
reinforcement learning algorithm
that uses deep learning deep
neural networks to approximate
the Q function, I will end with
the Q function and we have also
learned about the Q learning
algorithm when we were solving
that chapter. So, we have
basically I have written all the
steps that we will be using to
solve the Cardpool environment
using the DQ n algorithm. Then
we have implemented the class
for that as well. Then we come
to the training section. During
training the Q network is
updated using the Bellman
equation I have explained the
Bellman equation as well, to
minimize the mean squared error
between the predicted Q values
and the target Q values. The
Target Q values are computed
using the Q network but with the
weights frozen and not updated
during the current iteration of
training. Now, we have some
important concepts here. So
basically, this is the Select
Action, maybe P start and we
have plot durations, where we
paste the case what I have
explained to you all these hyper
parameters as well. Let's go to
a very important concept that is
Adam optimizer. So Adam adaptive
moment estimation is a popular
optimization algorithm that is
commonly used in deep learning.
It is an extension of stochastic
gradient descent, which is the
most basic optimization
algorithm used to train neural
networks. The main idea behind
it is to combine the advantages
of two other optimization
techniques added an RMS block.
Here I've explained in detail
how we'll be using it in our DQ
n algorithm. Next, we get the
number of actions from the
geometric space we set up, we
set the environment and get the
initial state, we set up the
number of features that we have,
we have the atom optimizer, we
have initialized our training
neural network as well, we have
the replay memory which is a
10,000 buffer, which is
contained 10,000 last 10,000
episodes, then, basically this
is a training loop, I explained
in detail as well, then we have
the optimized model, this method
will optimize the model. So
basically what we need to do is
we need to just take a mini
batch. So and also we will be
using sampling as well. To have
gone to that now you have
started with the training. So
we'll take that if CUDA is
available that is a GPU is
available, then we'll do six
minutes because or else we'll
only find it episodes. So yeah,
this is the training loop. And
then we have plotted the end
result. This chart I've also
explained in detail how we use
this chart to understand the
performance of our algorithm.
Now we've completed our solving
of logic using Q learning. So
basically, let's move on to the
advanced topics that we are
going to do go to cover and get
you will explore after learning
this beginners tutorial. So you
could explore deep reinforcement
learning. Deep Reinforcement
learning is a combination of
deep learning and reinforcement
learning that uses neural
networks to approximate the Q
values in Q learning. Deep RL
algorithms such as deep Q
network and actor critic have
been successful in solving
complex tasks such as Atari
Games robotics and autonomous
driving. So, basically, this is
what you can explore, you can
dive into autonomous driving
now. Policy gradients policy
gradient algorithms directly
optimize the policy function by
adjusting the parameters of the
policy to gradient Set. This
allows the agent to learn a
policy that maximize the that
maximizes the expected reward
without competing the Q values.
The advantage of policy gradient
algorithm is that they can
handle continuous action spaces,
unlike Q learning. So this is
pretty interesting. You can also
explore this. Now let's move on
to multi agent reinforcement
learning. Yeah, so this is
pretty interesting. Now you can
have two three cars in an
environment and you can simulate
that. And you can use petting
zoo for that. So petting zoo is
a brother of Guinness. And it
allows it gives us an
environment for multi agent
reinforcement learning. Multi
agent reinforcement learning
extends reinforcement learning
to the scenario where multiple
agents interact with each other
in a shared environment. In
multi reinforcement learning,
each multi agent reinforcement
learning agent learns his policy
based on the joint reward
received by all agents. The
opening a gymnasium toolkit
provides environments for MRL
such as the classic prisoner's
dilemma game and cooperative
navigation tasks. So there's
some pretty interesting
imitation learning, also known
as learning from demonstration
is a technique that trains an
agent to mimic the behavior of
an expert. This approach has
been used in various
applications such as autonomous
driving, robotics and game
learning. And genbrain Open AI
gymnasium toolkit include
environments from imitation
learning such as Motoko humanoid
locomotion task flow, this also
sounds pretty interesting. Now
let's look at the last topic
that you could cover in the
advanced topics to discuss
transfer learning. transfer
learning is the technique of
transferring knowledge learned
in one task to another task. In
reinforcement learning, transfer
learning can help speed up the
learning process and improve the
performance of the agent. The
Albany gymnasium toolkit
provides environments for
transfer learning, such as the
classic inverted pendulum does
and card polls wind up just so
now we talked about multi agent
reinforcement learning, so let's
check out putting zoo
documentation that I mentioned.
So what we can do is here you
can check out all the different
types of environment that are
available. So what are the games
we have pulled up? Here we have
Mario Bros for multi agents of
Luigi and Mario here on the
action space is defined so I've
explained all the concepts here
so it wouldn't be very difficult
for you to start implementing
these. We have Space Invaders
will be basically these are
different types of games
available. Let's check out
classic games. We have chest
Solibri chest as well. So I
highly encourage you to go first
Lex was when you understand the
basics, then I highly encourage
you to go out and check out the
petting zoo documentation and
study creating your own
environments and your own agents
and solve some real world
problems.